you know how sometimes kids ask the most
difficult questions
if a four-year-old asks you why do
things exist
you'd probably struggle to give them a
decent answer because we don't really
know
if we peel away the layers of complexity
from humans
to cells to molecules to atoms to
subatomic particles
we reach the standard model of particle
physics
which is our best description so far of
the fundamental
machinery of the universe but it doesn't
really answer why anything exists
but it does describe what exists and how
it behaves
and that's what we'll be discovering in
this video although
it's probably not actually suitable for
four-year-olds
uh but for the rest of us this is a
crash course in the fundamental rules of
particle physics
and it will help set the context for
future news when
people claim to have evidence beyond the
standard model of particle physics
you know it's good to first of all
understand what the standard model
is so that's what this video is for
we know the standard model isn't
complete there's lots of unresolved
mysteries which i'll be taking a look at
at the end of the video particle physics
is one of the main branches of
fundamental physics
i've briefly covered it before in the
map of physics and
in the map of quantum physics but here
we're going to dig deeper and i'm going
to tell you all the basics of the
fundamental particles of the standard
model
which i've summarized in this map which
like all my others is available for free
digitally
and for money as a physical poster links
in the description
so here are all the fundamental
particles we've discovered so far
this set is what everything in the
universe is made of
there are a few distinctions to point
out these are called the fermions
and these are the bosons fermions make
up the physical matter in the universe
and the bosons mediate how those matter
particles interact with each other
and so also known as force carriers or
exchange
particles but technically the thing that
sets them apart is a specific quantity
called
spin the fermions all over a spin of a
half
and the bosons have got a spin of one or
zero for the higgs boson
you can see these values in the chart
here
spin in quantum mechanics is a form of
angular momentum
which in general is some kind of
rotating motion
but spin specifically exists within
elementary particles it's also known as
intrinsic angular momentum
but spin is a bit of a confusing name
because it's not the same as classical
spin like spinning a basketball
there's no classical analog for spin so
i've actually got no idea how to draw a
picture of quantum spin
so this is the best i can do but this is
just an analogy
in quantum mechanics every particle has
a wave function
and the spin of a particle tells us how
the wave function behaves
under rotation in 3d space so
when we rotate the spin one particle we
see
face one then two then face 1 again
so for a spin one particle the wave
function looks the same after one full
rotation
but for a spin half particle you need
two full rotations
so as you rotate it you see face one
then face
two then face three then face
two then back to one again so the wave
function looks the same
only after two full rotations
hopefully that gives you a decent
picture of spin but
um it's a complex topic which i won't
really be able to do justice in the time
frame of this video
but how it works isn't the important
thing for us for this video the
important things are the consequences of
these different kinds of spin
and there's two things you need to know
about the first is that spin has to be
conserved
is one of the conservation laws of
particle physics
basically there are a bunch of rules
about how particles can interact with
each other
these are known as the conservation laws
of particle physics
and they say that there are certain
quantities
like spin that you can't create or
destroy in a particle interaction
the same amount of spin going into a
reaction needs to come out at the other
end
one example is an electron and an
anti-electron known as a positron which
come together and annihilate into a
photon
this is allowed because the particles
going in have got a spin of a half
each and they add together to give the
photon spin of one
so the same amount of spin came out as
went in and so spin is conserved
there's a number of other conservation
laws which we'll meet throughout this
video
i'll just mention the two most
fundamental conservation laws
energy and linear momentum which along
with angular momentum
apply to everything in physics not just
particles
actually that's not quite true these
aren't conserved in general relativity
if space-time is changing
but we don't have to worry about that
for this video
so this is the first consequence of spin
the second is even more dramatic
when you get a bunch of fermions
together collectively they behave
very differently to when you get bosons
together in a group
when you get fermions together they obey
a rule called the parolee exclusion
principle which says that fermions can't
share the same quantum state
and this is a very good thing the paraly
exclusion principle is what makes the
electrons in atoms populate all of the
energy shells
if it didn't exist they'd all collapse
into the lowest energy state and atoms
would behave very differently
because it's the outer electrons in each
of the elements that sets the kind of
chemical bonds those atoms can make
and chemistry creates all of the
complexity in the universe
so without the parallel exclusion
principle every atom in the periodic
table would behave
almost identically to hydrogen and so
none of the complexity that makes up
chemistry and biology including us would
exist because
nothing would be solid when we sit on a
chair it's essentially the power
exclusion principle that's stopping us
from just slothing through
bosons are different they're allowed to
share the same quantum state and this
results in some really interesting
quantum phenomena like
super fluidity superconductivity lasers
and many more
and a more fundamental level all of the
forces we know of come from a host of
virtual bosons
interacting with real particles
interestingly it isn't just the
fundamental particles that these rules
apply to the bose statistics for bosons
the parallely exclusion principle for
fermions
they apply to collections of particles
as well
so for example helium is known as a
composite boson
as it has two electrons which have spin
half each
if you add these spins together you get
a whole number a boson
this means that helium atoms behave like
bosons
and if you collect a load of helium
atoms together and cool them down into a
liquid
they will all inhabit the same quantum
state
and become a superfluid with zero
viscosity
which means it can do weird things like
flow up walls
also all the amazing properties of
superconductors like having zero
resistance
comes from electrons coming together to
form a boson called a cooper pair
and all these cooper pairs having the
same quantum state
so fermions and bosons are more general
than i previously stated
a fermion is anything with a total spin
of a half integer
and a boson is anything with a total
spin being a whole integer
okay that covers the consequences of
spin now let's take a closer look at the
spin half particles the fermions
now you'll notice that the fermions are
also split into the quarks and the
leptons
we'll look at the quarks first a single
quark can't ever exist on its own
quarks are always found bundled together
the up and down quarks make protons and
neutrons which make up all of the
elements
but quarks can also be joined together
in other configurations like a pion
which is a particle made of a quark
and an antiquark pair like the electrons
these quarks all carry electric
charge but they have different amounts
these ones have a charge of two-thirds
and these have a charge of minus
one-third
these all add together to give the
overall charge for example a proton is
made up of up up down quarks
and so has an overall charge of a plus
one
but a neutron is made up of up down down
quarks where the charges all cancel out
for an overall charge of zero
charge is another quantity that's
conserved in particle interaction so we
should add that to the list
quarks interact with all of the
fundamental forces
let me just explain what i'm showing
here each of these show which particles
interact with each of the fundamental
forces
we've got the electromagnetic force the
strong force and the weak force
so you can see here that the quarks
interact with all of these forces
also of note the quarks are the only
particles that
feel the strong force along with the
carriers of the strong force the gluons
you'll notice i've used the word field
here instead of force
and this comes from quantum field theory
which are the fundamental rules that
dictate how particles interact
quantum field theory states that there
is a field associated with each of the
fundamental particles
and particles are really excited states
also known as quanta of their field
so these forces are carried by specific
fields
which is what we mean when we say that
these bosons are force carriers
we also need to add the higgs field
which doesn't cause a force
but these particles highlighted here get
their mass
from interacting with the higgs field
the other quarks the charm strange top
and bottom quarks
they're just like the up and down quarks
but they've got larger masses
also they're unstable in the first
fraction of a second after the big bang
all of these decays down into the up and
down quarks by the weak force
but that doesn't mean they don't exist
in the universe today you can still find
these heavier quarks
in high energy cosmic environments
things like
supernovae or neutron stars and we also
create them in our particle accelerators
now from the quarks we've got a couple
more conservation rules to add to the
list
barion number and color charge a barian
is another technical term which i'll
explain
the proton and neutron are both baryons
but more generally a baryon is any
particle made up
of an odd number of quarks but at least
three quarks because quarks can't exist
on their own
barrier number is plus a third for each
of the quarks and minus a third for the
antiquarks
so these add together to give a plus one
barion number for the proton and the
neutron
and is minus one for antiprotons and
antineutrons
i haven't talked about antiparticles yet
so let's do that now
here's a version of the standard model
but i've drawn all of the antiparticles
as well as the particles
as you can see all of the fermions have
got antiparticle partners
which have got the same mass as the
regular particles but have got an
opposite
everything else like charge or barrier
number
and other kinds of quantum numbers we'll
be meeting some more quantum numbers
along the way
the next one is color charge which we'll
look at now
color charge is a property of quarks and
gluons and is an important part of the
strong force interaction
conceptually color charge is similar to
the electric charge
but instead of two kinds of charge there
are actually three kinds of color charge
which physicists have labeled red green
and blue
there's a restriction on the kinds of
quarks that can join together to make a
proton or neutron
the rule is that you need to have the
composite particle be color neutral
which means for a proton or a neutron
you need one quark of each colour
the analogy physicists are using here is
that the primary colours red green and
blue add together to make white
which we're calling colour neutral in
fact you can see an example of this
color edition here if you look really
closely at a pixel on your screen right
now
from a distance it looks white but if
you zoom in they're actually red blue
and green added together
but we shouldn't take this analogy too
literally quark color has got nothing to
do with color as we
experience it through photons of light
physicists
discovered the rules of quark colour
conservation and the mixing of primary
colours of light just happened to be
a useful analogy that fit quite well
antiquarks have got anti-color so a
green and an
anti-green quark can come together and
make a pion particle which has got
neutral
colour charge because the colours cancel
out now there's actually an alternative
analogy to the colour charge thing which
i quite like
instead of colors we've got arrows that
always point in specific directions as
shown here
to have red color charge means to point
in this direction
specifically and no other these arrows
can't be rotated
now you can use these arrows to create
valid particles
a valid combination of quarks is one
where the quark arrows make a closed
path
so a proton or a neutron would look like
this just an equilateral triangle
an antiproton or antineutron would look
like this
and we can extend this out to other
shapes like a pion
or a particle made of two quarks and two
antiquarks called a tetra quark
and what's cool is any other shape you
can come up with which makes a closed
path
is also possible this is nice because i
find it a more intuitive analogy than
the color wheel so i thought i'd tell
you about it
now quarks can interact with each other
through the strong force and this is
where the gluons come in
there are actually eight kinds of gluons
each with a different
colour anti-colour pair and through
these gluons the different quarks
interact with each other
so now if i add the colour charges to
the standard model diagram along with
all the anti-particles
we get this this is actually all of the
fundamental particles that make up the
universe
which i think is important to show
because there are a lot more than in the
normal standard model diagrams
okay so that completes my description of
the quarks
so now let's add some extra conservation
rules to the chart
conservation of barrier number and
conservation of color charge
now let's move on to the other half of
the fermions the leptons
here they all are and here's the most
famous one the electron which is the
hardest working particle
responsible for chemical bonds
electricity
atoms emitting and receiving photons of
light amongst others
modern society is entirely built on our
ability to get electrons to do what we
want them to do
so they're pretty cool the muon and tau
particles are identical to the electron
just with higher masses and they're
unstable just like the heavier quarks
all the muon and tau particles that were
created in the big bang decayed into
electrons in the first fraction of a
second
via the weak force which released lots
of neutrinos and photons that are still
flying around the universe today
new muons are also created in natural
processes one example is cosmic rays
hitting the atmosphere
but any other natural process with high
enough energy will produce muons and
towers as well
here are the field interaction charts
again and this time let's look at the
leptons
the electron muon and tau interact with
everything
except the strong force and get their
masses from the higgs field
below them are the neutrinos which have
got very small masses and don't carry
electric
charge and so these only interact with
the weak force
because of this they're very difficult
to detect as they interact with mata
very very rarely
there are three kinds of neutrino an
electron neutrino a muon neutrino and a
tau neutrino
and these different kinds of lepton each
have their own quantum number
which you can think of as electroneus
muon-nus
and taunus tauwishness i don't know i'm
making these words up
in physics we actually call them
different lepton flavors
these lepton flavors are another
conserved quantum number
we can see this in this vitamin diagram
of beta decay where the w boson decays
into an electron and an electron
anti-neutrino
the electron has an electron number of
plus one and the electron anti-neutrino
has got an electron number of minus one
because it's an anti-particle so these
two numbers cancel out to zero
which is what we started with and so the
electron lepton number is conserved
it's important to note that the
different flavors of lepton are
independent
so for example an anti-muon wouldn't
cancel out an electron
this means we've got three more
conservation rules to add to the
conservation laws
chart i want to say a little bit more
about the neutrinos because we still
don't fully understand them
it's difficult to study neutrinos
because they don't interact with matter
very often
the sun is constantly spewing out
neutrinos from the nuclear processes
inside
and in any second we've got 400 billion
neutrinos traveling through our body
like it's not even there for a long time
neutrinos were thought to be massless
but we now know that each neutrino has
its own
very small mass we don't know what this
mass is
and it's still being investigated but we
know that it's greater than zero
and the sum of all three neutrino masses
must be less than 0.3 electron volts
because they have mass neutrinos can
oscillate between the different lepton
flavors
for example electro neutrinos produced
by beta decay have been observed
to have a different flavor when measured
in a distant detector
another mysterious property of neutrinos
is to do with their chirality
which here i'm going to be simplifying
as their handedness or helicity in order
to draw you a picture
which basically all means whether
they're left-handed or right-handed
we've observed left-handed or
right-handed versions of every other
particle
but with neutrinos we've only ever
observed them to be left-handed
never right-handed and for
anti-neutrinos we've only ever seen
right-handed anti-neutrinos and not
left-handed ones
here i've actually drawn the helicity
which is how the spin
aligns with linear momentum because i
don't actually know how to draw
chirality
i'm only mentioning this because there's
a subtle difference between chirality
and helicity
in any particle with mass in massless
particles chirality and helicity
end up being the same thing but i'm i'm
really getting into the weeds here
we don't really need to worry about that
for this video the main point is we
don't know
why we only get left-handed neutrinos
and it breaks a couple of symmetries in
physics called parity symmetry
and charge symmetry okay before we get
into the next bit i'm just going to give
us a bit of a break
because the next bit's quite a lot to
get your head around
so this is a bit of a breather basically
neutrinos are kind of weird
and there's still a very active area of
research going on to try and study them
but they're hard to study because
they don't really interact with anything
but it's interesting there's more
neutrinos in the universe than photons
so clearly they're very important
okay let's get back to the symmetries of
physics
asymmetry in physics is an important
concept to understand
if we change some global property like
in an instant we turn the universe into
a mirror image copy of itself
the question is would the laws of
physics be the same after that
transformation
if so the universe would be symmetrical
with respect to mirror images
which is technically known as parity
symmetry so
is the universe actually parity
symmetric the answer is yes
except for the neutrinos this is because
a left-handed neutrino in the original
universe
gets turned into a right-handed neutrino
in the mirror universe
but right-handed neutrinos don't exist
so the two universes
aren't symmetric
for a similar reason neutrinos also
break another symmetry called charge
conjugation symmetry
which is if you instantaneously turned
all of the particles in the universe
into their antiparticle counterparts
would the universe look and continue the
same
mostly it would but again not for the
neutrinos
if you have a left-handed neutrino and
you flipped it into an anti-particle
it would become a left-handed
anti-neutrino
which doesn't exist so if we go over our
conservation laws again
in most cases in physics the mirror
image or parity symmetry does hold
it's conserved but not by the weak force
interaction that produces neutrinos
and the same goes for charge symmetry
but interestingly
if you apply both transformations parity
and
charge this combination is conserved by
these weak force interactions
because both transformations get you
back to a valid neutrino
so this combination called charge parity
conservation or cp conservation
is a more general conservation law which
actually applies to everything
except it doesn't in the 1960s it was
found that the chaos
a specific kind of particle made up of a
strange quark and an
up or down antiquark they don't obey cp
conservation
and subsequently many other examples of
cp violation have been found in particle
interactions
but if we also add time reversal
symmetry into the mix
which is does the universe look the same
if we run time backwards
compared to forwards so we take particle
interaction
then we flip parity and then charge and
then time
this combination of transformations is
conserved by all
particle interactions and this is known
as cpt
symmetry did that make sense uh maybe
not
it's a lot to take in but historically
physicists have been more and more
frustrated that they need to relax these
conservation laws
as it makes the overall standard model
less and less elegant
the main takeaway point from all of this
is that we've got different conservation
laws which are conserved by the
different forces
anything within this box is conserved by
the weak force
anything in this box is conserved by the
electromagnetic force
and anything in this box is conserved by
the strong force
and as we're here i'll just fill in the
rest of these conservation laws
strangeness is a quantum number attached
to strange quarks which is violated by
the weak force but conserved elsewhere
and this is also true for the other
flavour quantum numbers charm
top and bottom i mentioned time reversal
earlier but
it basically says the laws of physics
look exactly the same if we flip the
arrow of time and run it backwards
interestingly this is actually
equivalent to cp symmetry which i just
talked about and
this isn't conserved by the weak force
but it is by the others
and finally we have isospin z component
and isospin magnitude
which are quantum numbers to do with the
up and down quarks
but i'll be honest i don't understand
these well enough to do a concise
summary here
but i've included them for completeness
and so now at least you know that they
exist
okay so let's do a quick review of what
we've covered so far i've described the
fermions which contain the quarks and
the leptons
we've also seen all the conservation
laws as well as all the field
interactions for all of the particles
these standard model interactions at the
bottom are a summary of all the possible
particle interactions that are allowed
by the standard model
which i looked at in my previous video
on feynman diagrams
so go watch that if you'd like more
details on them i won't cover them in
this video
this brings us to the last part of the
standard model we need to look at the
bosons
also known as exchange particles also
known as force carriers
the glue ones we've already covered when
i talked about color charge and the
strong force
the photons are how you are seeing right
now they carry the electromagnetic force
and interact with anything with electric
charge
which is all of these particles however
the photons don't carry electric charge
themselves
so they don't interact with each other
which is why i haven't included them on
this
chart even though they're the carriers
of the electromagnetic force
it's a funny thought that because light
is how we see
things we can't actually see light
as in we can't see it traveling past us
because we can't bounce light off it as
it travels past because
light's not self-interacting but it's
kind of crazy to imagine what the
universe would look like if
photons did actually bounce off each
other we wouldn't be able to see
anything because just
the air or empty space would no longer
be transparent
you'd just see a jumble of like random
photons
everywhere and it would be a mess so
it's a good thing that
photons aren't self-interacting
the w and z bosons are the force
carriers for the weak force and have got
very large masses
which they get from interacting with the
higgs field
the z boson doesn't carry electric
charge though only interacts with the
weak force
but the w boson can have either a
positive or negative electric charge
so interacts with the electromagnetic
force as well as the weak force
and finally we have the higgs boson
which comes from the higgs
field and particles get their masses
from interacting with the higgs field
when they move through it apart from of
course the neutrinos
the neutrinos get their mass from some
other mechanism which we haven't worked
out yet
which is just one of our outstanding
mysteries in particle physics
the higgs boson itself has got mass
because the higgs field is
self-interacting
and the higgs fields has got a different
nature to the other fields and so
doesn't result in a force like the
strong weak or electromagnetic forces
technically the higgs field is a scalar
field and not a vector field
like the others okay so that's my
summary of the standard model of
particle physics
but before i go i want to talk about
gravity when we learn physics we learn
that the four fundamental forces are
electromagnetism
the strong force the weak force and
gravity
but i haven't mentioned gravity until
now that's because we don't have a
quantum description of gravity
gravity is described by general
relativity as the result of a curved
space time
people have predicted a gravity particle
called a graviton
which would be the particle associated
with gravitational waves
but unfortunately there's no way we can
make a particle accelerator with high
enough energies to probe this because
gravity is so weak in comparison to the
other forces
even so physicists have been trying to
squash the standard model
and general relativity together for
nearly a century now
to try and make a theory of quantum
gravity like string theory
or a quantum theory of space time like
loop quantum gravity
i've done a previous video on all of
this if you want to find out more
now that's not an end to the mysteries
in particle physics let's take a look at
a few more
a big question is the issue of baryon
asymmetry
according to the standard model at the
big bang mata and antimatter particles
were created in even
amounts but if we look at the universe
today
everything we see is made of matter and
not antimatter
so where did all the antimatter go we
don't know
physicists have also made theoretical
predictions of more fundamental
particles beyond the standard model
stuff we haven't discovered yet
the most famous of these were the
supersymmetric particles which
should have been detected by the lhc but
weren't
so currently it's not looking good for
the theory of supersymmetry
also the most popular theory to explain
dark matter
is that it's made of some kind of
particle we haven't detected yet
although there are many efforts to do
just this
other questions are why are there
exactly three generations of quarks and
leptons
what are the masses of the neutrinos
what combinations of quarks are possible
and what's up with the recent results on
muon procession frequency
protons are very stable particles but do
they ever decay
neutrons aren't stable but what exactly
is the lifetime of a neutron
do magnetic monopoles exist is there a
planck particle
why is gravity so weak what
what is time as ever in science
more research is needed so what does the
future of particle physics look like
historically we've built bigger and
bigger accelerators to collide particles
at higher and higher energies
in order to recreate the conditions
billionths of a second after the big
bang
but building new accelerators that are
bigger than the ones that exist today
would cost tens of billions of dollars
which might be a tough sell so we'll
have to see what happens there
but there are many experiments we can
still do with the current generation of
particle accelerators
and as well we've got several large
detectors without particle accelerators
which are mostly giant vats of liquid
deep underground looking at high energy
neutrinos
or trying to detect dark matter
particles
here's just a quick sponsor message
before i round the video up
this bit sponsored by brilliant it's a
website an app chock full of science and
mathematics content in the form of
question based
courses watching youtube videos is great
but to really learn something it takes
practice and one excellent option is
brilliant with its interactive questions
which coach you bit by bit
through a variety of courses in physics
mathematics and computer science
from the fundamentals like geometry or
classical mechanics
right through to cutting-edge subjects
like cryptocurrency or quantum computing
there's something for everybody i like
it because i can pick it up at any time
on my phone and actually do something
useful
instead of just doom scrolling twitter
again
and after a bit of phone time i've
actually learned something which feels
great
if you're interested you can go to my
special link brilliant.org
dos or you can click on the first link
in the description below
and this helps me out because they know
you've come from here and on top of that
the first 200 people to sign up will get
a 20
discount on the premium subscription
which unlocks all of their content
but there is a lot of content on there
for free and they're adding courses all
the time so it's worth checking out in
any case
ah so that's it we've reached the end of
the video um
i hope it's been helpful i'm aware that
there's a huge amount of information to
take in
but i've summarized all in this image
which you can study in your own time
like all of my posters the digital
version is free to download for your own
use or educational uses
but you can buy a physical poster as
well from my dftba store
and if you've got an inkling to buy it
this is a fantastic way to support me
and my channel
to help me make more videos like this i
obviously put a lot of work into them
this was a huge amount of work for this
video and i want them to be available as
a free educational resource
i've also got many kind people
supporting me on patreon which is
fantastic for me to uh surf the
very unpredictable waves of the youtube
algorithm
um okay don't worry about subscribing
unless you really want to but do check
back every so often because i've got a
lot of videos lined up and you can't
necessarily rely on youtube actually
showing them to you
when they come out but if you check back
on my channel every couple of months or
so you should be fine
also if you know someone who you think
might be interested in this video share
it with them
that'd be cool otherwise thank you for
watching
and i'll see you soon
you